so it is a race against the clock to
make sure those last minute gifts make
it under your christmas tree on time
that's right this morning we're taking a
peek inside amazon's fulfillment center
up in north las vegas hector mejia is
there
good morning guys and here's your inside
look at the fulfillment center here in
north las vegas chances are those are
either those christmas gifts going
through the conveyor belt perhaps your
lipstick or even that christmas train
you bought for little tommy out there
for christmas day joining us this
morning we have time to explain to us
just exactly what's going on during this
week of christmas good morning sir yeah
good morning so
we've been preparing for the last 10
months all the way up until november for
the holiday season there's a lot of
excitement all around all of our
employees in order to deliver this
holiday season for our customers so here
we have
an 855 000 square foot building where we
employ over 5 000 employees
and there's so much going on right now
so many packages going through the
conveyor belt we have people really
everywhere inside this warehouse yes
that's correct so today we're actually
going to be shipping over 700 000
customer orders and then bringing 800
000 customer products back into the
building and that is today alone that's
today alone not to mention the gifts for
christmas day yeah exactly our employees
are really excited about it all right so
lastly let's talk about those deadlines
what are the cutoff dates for people to
get those christmas gifts in time for
christmas day so prime members can order
one day delivery all the way through the
23rd of december we are going to be
continuing to deliver products all the
way through the 24th for our customers
but then there's also options like whole
foods there's a pop-up shop at the vegas
fashion show mall
where you can also get products on the
24th awesome tom thank you so much for
having us inside so there's a lot going
on in here a big operation it doesn't
happen every day when we get axes inside
this facility we'll be back in less than
half an hour with a look at how they're
dealing with a possible supply chain
problem here locally that's still ahead
of the next half hour reporting in north
las vegas hector mejia live local now